learner transfer station Tacoma
commercial cargo transit facility who
evacuated fish may I applying air supply
breathable air until Kobach's Eric
remote one should be more than
sufficient nothing now Tacoma tells a
story split into two parts the microcosm
of a small cast of characters and in the
background the bigger picture
surrounding them meticulous attention to
detail makes even the most mundane
things like a forgotten book in a corner
or a bottle of shampoo captivating and
strong voice acting and writing gives
surprising depth to characters who are
physically absent from the story itself
the big picture is interesting in its
own right but it mostly runs parallel to
the smaller details rather than
meaningfully intersecting with them
[Music]
in Tacoma you take on the role of Amy
farrier a subcontractor who is tasked
with retrieving AI hardware and records
from the Tacoma Space Station though the
six-person crew is gone you're able to
recover short augmented reality
recordings of their final days on the
station interacting with these
recordings comprises the majority of
your time investigating Tacoma you
listen in on one conversation before
rewinding and following different crew
members through the same period of time
hearing their conversations and reading
their AR desktops is both intimate and
lonely in a way that's immediately
compelling one of the first recordings
you find involves the crews setting up
for a party before an object strikes the
station rupturing the oxygen tanks it
was captured three days before your
arrival which means you're seeing the
hologram outlines of the crew mime party
preparations among the debris that
followed trash and fallen decorations
tell the story of the recording doesn't
that the crew worried and scared left
everything where it fell I have righted
the station's orbit so there's no oxygen
on the station except while we're
breathing right now correct with two
plus days of oxygen left many of the
recordings involve the crew arguing
problem solving or comforting one
another even without facial animations
of any kind it's easy to read their
emotions mostly due to phenomenal acting
from the cast but to really understand
their dynamics you have to poke around
their emails and IMS the books and keep
sticks in their bunks and the few
recordings that capture them alone no
one seen character or object is more
important than any other things like
photos or im's only become meaningful
when you figure out their context so
each new piece of information works in
tandem with everything else you found
there's a couple on Tacoma NAT and Bert
who are almost always together on one
level you get to know them as a pair
through their spoken conversations but
there's another layer consisting of
private IMS and emails that develops
them as individuals early on for example
you can listen in on NAT expressing
frustrations about life and work on
Tacoma to Bert
later in a private message Bert reveals
the
that she's holding that back but it
first seems like a potential source of
conflict between them but NAT never
blames Burt for their situation even
direct messages to others that
complexity underlying their interactions
makes them feel more real rather than
devices that exist solely to create more
drama and when I do like myself stop
thinking about how this a possibility
this is the last of our time together to
the station features an AI named Odin
who serves as the main confidant for one
of the crew members Sarah artificial
intelligence in the politics of
automation are a huge source of conflict
off the station according to articles
and emails you can find around tacoma
sarah's friendship with odin is the main
connection between the narrative on
tacoma and the bigger picture stuff
outside of it but it feels incomplete
like some of the details that could
contextualize it further or missing part
of that is your inability to access
Odin's private thoughts since he doesn't
have anything like an AR desktop but
mostly it feels like the foundation
isn't as layered as everything else in
Tacoma it's not that there's not enough
information but that it's under explored
until the end which dulls the impact of
an otherwise engaging story it's not to
say that Tacoma isn't impactful I'm
still thinking about it inferring what
wasn't spelled out for me and wondering
about the complex politics of its near
future world mostly though I'm deeply
attached to the Tacoma crew who I only
got to know through projections and the
things they left behind out of
everything that's tacoma's greatest
accomplishment getting you to care about
people who aren't even there
while the board to comb station please
remember that all activity on this
facility is monitored by a are recording
all activity records become sole
property of the venturous corporation
any questions
[Music]